I don't know where to start I think the
Last Jedi is really great wait Revenge
of the Sith was your entry point into
Star Wars ah there's only ever been one
answer on the street celebrate Star Wars
what's your favorite Star Wars movie or
TV
[Music]
show I don't know where to start She's
Got a Cool vibe I know she's from the
Clone Wars not a Jedi and a rebel I
believe that's a lotion they sell in bed
bed and beyond no it's actually a Star
Wars character during the Clone Wars was
being trained momentarily by Anakin like
she was his Padawan essentially before
he turned to the dark side you know in
the prequel movies never saw her but you
know the animated show she was a big
character and only the real nerds like
us would would ever know about so and
then she popped up in Mandalorian and
now she's got her own show right kind of
like how Frasier was in cheers initially
and then he got his own spin-off same
thing happening with Star Wars my
brother and I watched the Clone Wars
growing up and so so he and I like
Ahsoka a lot I guess she's always been
my character I always see myself like in
her yeah she's more independent I guess
neutral to that kind of like the
Switzerland of outer space yeah exactly
she kind of seems like she's the Jedi
who really doesn't care about the rules
but just wants to do the right thing but
she's like not about to do it the right
way if it takes longer but from what
I've heard though about the Ahsoka show
it's like really really good I think
that's the one you should check out you
know I just saw the more recent episode
last night was really well done it's
interesting I think some of the filming
is almost like some of the original
movies where it seems a little slow in
some capacity but I think it
stylistically is just sort of a a choice
that they made you really know your Star
Wars I am a little bit of a Star Wars
nerd he was he was like I don't know
that much about Star Wars you get him on
camera the guy should be hosting the
damn
show Empire Strikes Back I like Empire
Strikes Back The Empire Strikes Back my
favorite was Rog one Rogue one you know
what Return of the Jedi screw it Return
of the Jedi Return of the Jedi revenge
of the SI the double that revenge of the
SI the 1977 classic I think A New Hope
is New Hope I love just getting to know
the world just experiencing that for the
first time you always remember your
first time I mean allegedly yes I'll
I'll let you know when it
happen I kind of want to be chaotic and
just I think Last Jedi is really great
like I genuinely do that's the one that
like the more I watch the more I think
about it the more I think it is good
what was it about Rogue one that you
like so much I think I just like the
characters a lot it's not just a
Blockbuster but it also has the
character and the feelings throughout
for me Rogue one just kind of brought to
a new generation better than the
socalled new Trilogy which was just a
rehash of the old ones that's a lot of
answer for uh your favorite Star Wars
movie I know what I'm talking about
great kid don't get cocky I've only seen
one Star Wars movie ever Revenge of the
Sith liar wait Revenge of the Sith was
your entry point into Star Wars school
they were doing a screening for it
Revenge of the Sith for me cuz that's
kind of just like my generation it
connects it to The Originals I really
just love Anakin Skywalkers Arc Anakin
turning to the dark side gets me every
time that scene with him and Obi-Wan
whenever he like gets his legs chopped
off and he's crying that's probably my
favorite I mean it's a pretty emotional
powerful kind of scene it it is and you
see like it's really what connects two
generations of Star Wars fans like a
good volcanic climax yeah there we go
yeah cool word to
[Music]
[Applause]
say I can't pick it depends on the day I
mean I'm partial to the OG's I love Luke
I love Leia I love Han and I do love Ray
the rxs are riches you know the the the
lower tier and then going like a hero
especially for all the little girls that
want to be Jedi and I think that's just
so cool Han Solo I just feel like
there's a bit of unpredictability with
him Palpatine real big fan of the
emperor yeah he's cold that dude's cold
he he was so evil and Insidious I'm
going to say Obi-Wan thank goodness
you're here I think when he came back
and face Darth Vader as Darth Vader this
time kind of did like if you strike me
down in hatred I'll be with you forever
I thought that that was hard to tell oh
my God who was that one thing I loved
like I wanted to cry General Grievous oh
I loved him you love Grievous yes I
thought you were going to say R2-D2 and
you went Grievous oh Grievous what a guy
and then oh I was heartbroken tragic
ending for him yeah so
uncivilized ah there's only ever been
one answer uh Darth Vader I would say
Darth Vader Darth Vader yeah I would say
Anakin and Darth Vader most evely Anakin
he started out good but then you know he
took the Darth Vader role and he ran the
evil empire man he's very annoying as a
kid but becomes a really bad Dar of the
Vader character he's the good guy turned
bad guy turn good guy so you're saying
you weren't annoying as a
kid yeah I probably was if you had to
hang out and spend let's say a weekend
in Vegas with any Star Wars character
who would it be oh Han Solo for sure
yeah that's easy that was a much easier
answer yeah that's way easy I think I
would have more fun with Donald Glover
like or Lando he's just such a cool guy
I'm going with
Chewy I just came back from Vegas so
yeah you in chewy that's it in case
anybody acts up I got my bodyguard with
me too you certainly
do that does it for this episode of on
the street comment right now and let us
know what's the best Star Wars movie of
all time and what's your favorite Star
Wars TV show thanks for watching I'm
Mark Ellison until next time that famous
Star Wars quote what a wonderful smell
you've discovered thanks for checking
this fit out head over to rotten
tomatoes.com for everything in the world
of movies TV and in between hey folks
you want to talk Star Wars with us we're
here with Barrett all right don't make
your voice sad D you can't be deeper
than mine use the force
Luke obw no yeah I know who it was and
welcome to Star Wars thank you I'm
excited